hello everybody matt luigi here and
today february 9th bungie has taken down
their halo stats page later this year
xbox live servers for the 360 era halo
games will be dropped
and this might be kind of minor news to
most people but
uh it's all it to be fair it's minor
news to me too um but
halo was a big part of my life so these
events have gotten me a little
sentimental
and they've motivated me to make this
video which is an update video that i've
been wanting to make for a while
in the background there's going to be
some halo 3 gameplay from the mcc
match i played earlier today uh it's on
the map high ground
some team slayer br i'm going to snag
the first kill right here
not very clean anytime you see me with
the sniper it's not going to be very
clean
i'm playing with a mouse and keyboard
but i am not a good shot so
just a forewarning for you
and i wanted to make this video as an
update because i'm not dead
and this channel is been kind of dead
granted uh but it's just been in stasis
it's not been dead hopefully the return
from stasis is a little bit better than
chief's return
uh that we've seen in the new halo
trilogy uh
but yeah yeah hopefully it's a good
return
um and i'm gonna talk a little bit about
it a little bit about why i've been gone
in this video uh so i've had decent
reason to be gone i was finishing my
uh bachelor's degree bam easy kill once
again on that
that same guy from the start most of my
big kills are going to be on him bashful
uh i was finishing my bachelor's and
getting
my master's also finishing my masters
which are decent reasons
to um be busy to have other things to do
but they're not really good excuses uh
in the sense of
i wanted to keep making videos but i
didn't i had less time i had less energy
to put into videos
so it's fair um not an excuse but
what are you gonna do moving forward i
want to make more videos
i don't have any desire to have my
channel be dead it's kind of my little
corner of the internet
um i've been making videos since i was
14
or somewhere around there and i'm
turning 24 this year so
obviously this has been a big part of my
life and i want to keep doing it
uh so i'm going to keep doing it uh i
have the means to
i have the energy and the will and the
desire and the hope and the vision and
the drive
i have all of those things some more
than others some less than others
uh and i want to keep making videos
that's the
short and sweet of it they're going to
be probably a little bit different this
is once again bashful
we both kind of choke the shots but i
get the i get the assassinate so i pick
up the kill
these are going to be a little bit
different than my older videos just
because
they're not going to be strict like
tutorials or
dark souls 3 lore which has been a lot
of my channel as of
uh as of yet as as of this point
um once again we're gonna see basil and
we're gonna have quite the confrontation
uh i'll give him that one i'll give him
that one
um but i want to talk about i want to
talk about halo
specifically uh for one because
i love halo i love halo 3 it's probably
my favorite game ever
and past me just really liking it i
think there are a lot of things the game
does or the game did
really just seamlessly beautiful from
the
forge to custom games to theater mode to
bungie favorites
every week it was a lot of really really
really really
really cool stuff that i want to make a
video talking about halo in general and
specifically halo 3.
here that was just a complete joke that
was there was no excuse for
that terrible play um but i am a little
rusty so maybe that's an excuse
um but yeah i want to make more videos
uh making the big halo video
talking about a lot of the stuff that i
really like about it why it was
important to me what it did really well
i want to make some philosophy videos i
don't know if i already mentioned that
but
uh near automata and soma spring to to
my
spring to the mind as two games which
are
very primed for a video about the
philosophical
themes and elements of the games and
specifically how those games
use the fact that they are video games
they use their medium
to convey these ideas in ways that only
a video game could and they're also just
really good games
and with varying levels of flying under
the radar soma more than near
for sure uh but near
not really a mainstream game even if it
did get a good amount of popularity
so i'm a very much not a mainstream game
i would say uh
at least to my knowledge um so i want to
make a video talking about one
just talking about some cool games from
the last decade that are
really hype and maybe didn't get as much
hype as i think they should have
deserved like those two games
and uh some more specific directed
videos at
uh specific games like near and uh
soma talking about the philosophy behind
them and the philosophy
present in them because philosophy is a
really important thing to me as well and
i think there'd be
there's definitely space to talk about
philosophy and games more
um i'm gonna snipe this guy with the
second grenade
um something like halo 3 maybe not as
much i
just thinking about it not a lot springs
to mind in terms of philosophical impact
you can get from
a halo 3 or the halo series in general
at least the
original trilogy because while there
were definitely strong elements in the
story and whatnot
chief wasn't like a chief wasn't much of
a character he was literally just like a
player stand-in
to be fair and that's what developers
have said and
like chief isn't strongly characterized
in the original trilogy
regardless of how cool he is he's made
to just be a
cool cool dude who kills people and
aliens and anyone
in his way uh and that's fine like i
love the cheap
uh and i love what there was in halo
but just not a lot of philosophy which
is fine um but i want to talk about
philosophy in games i do have them
because it's a
really cool concept an intersection of
passions for me
and that's probably most of the stuff
that i wanted to talk about in this
video i
i don't want my channel to die
i don't plan on having to die or
continue to be dead if you have
viewed it as being dead which would be a
relatively fair view
um and i want to make more videos i want
to post more and i plan to it will
probably won't be
uh until a couple weeks till i get
another video out
um it's not like this video is going to
come out and then bam weekly videos
immediately start after that there's
going to be a ramp up period
um but it's i exist and that's um
that's bashful the same guy again
getting lasered
uh but that's um yeah that's what i want
to do
um with my channel with my videos
i don't know how many people are still
around i had about 20k subs but a lot of
them even
back in the day weren't super active i
i just uh completely tunnel vision on
that guy
a lot of them weren't super active uh i
did get a good amount of videos that
blew up though
um so yeah if you're still here if
you're still around from the old days
i appreciate it it's pretty cool if any
of you
are still around from the really old
days like the start of my channel when i
was posting minecraft videos about the
hair brine experience
kudos mad kudos to you like if you are
please comment because that would be
wild to me i'm going to finish this game
out getting the kill on bashfield and
getting
bodied by laser that i still don't know
if it's from an enemy or from my
teammate
uh regardless um
yeah let me know if you guys are still
around from the old days because that
would be really cool
and that's most of what i wanted to say
in this video i'm going to make more
videos
i'm still around i still exist and
hope you guys are going to be around for
the journey and if not that's
chill uh i think the videos i'm gonna
make are gonna be cool so
yeah and that one dude gym game he had
one kill in like
three games i played with him so if you
get on the mcc for one
because more people on the mcc the
better and there's plenty of people it's
not just sweaty
halo try hards it's tons of people and
for a very very brief excursion even
though my gameplay is over
halo's on on the pc which is wild like
we had
dori el dorito and uh the cartographer
project i think those are two different
things we had those for years which were
like
taking a halo port from russia that was
like not fully
developed or released and modding that
and making a new halo but we have
halo in its almost entirety because
screw halo 5
uh on the on the pc
we have halo 1 halo 1 like anniversary
halo 2 halo 2 anniversary halo 3 have a
380
halo 3 odst halo reach halo 4. like
it's a halo palooza so if you played
halo and you're like where's more halo
or if you didn't play halo get the mcc
because it's a sweet deal for all the
stuff you get
um yeah i'm going to talk more about
halo in my halo video
and i'm talking to a black screen so if
you made it this far
i am thoroughly impressed i'm impressed
that you care
for whatever reason about this specific
tangent to listen to this video with
blackness
uh for this long thank you um
say hi in the comments if you've been
around um hi
it's been a while uh and yeah thanks for
watching and i'm gonna see you in the
next video
peace